last night ABC as I said they they aired  their much-anticipated  interview with former FBI director James  Comey and it was full of scathing  criticisms of President Trump okay we  all knew that was coming I just thought  I don't know what you thought  I thought ABC was trying a little too  hard to play up the drama between Comey  and Trump  I thought they forced it a little bit it  bugged me take a look it was the first  time you met Donald Trump what was your  impression his tie was too long as it  always is he looked slightly orange up  close with a small white half-moons  under his eyes which I assume were from  tanning goggles  I honestly never thought these words  would come out of my mouth but I don't  know whether the current president  knighted States was with prostitutes  peeing on each other in Moscow in 2013  it's possible president Trump  obstructing justice  possibly Donald Trump unfit to be  President  yes he is morally unfit to be President  [Applause]  do that  you